dude oh my god
dude
what you
didn't I
didn't you didn't they did but I did I
did I did they didn't or they did but
you you shouldn't
have we really should have guys yeah so
happy birthday thank you we set up a DJ
booth but this is a special DJ booth
what is it cuz as you
DJ I can walk up to the booth right yeah
I'm like
yo you're my favorite DJ thanks I can
kick you right in the nuts oh that's why
it says kick me yeah so you know it's
like you're so good at this yeah thanks
oh
what do you want to hear Bad Bunny yeah
right come right up let me
just me this is my favorite
DJ you
know I didn't had to get that out way
well you broke the wrong one you killed
the wrong one why you should be killing
this
[Laughter]
one this is the one damn I didn't see
that okay
all no actually we do have a gift for
you you know last time it was a big
tease so this time maybe we get you a
gift you can actually use
okay yeah what do you mean last time it
was a tease last time it was a
tease but this time it can be one you
can actually
use is this why you asked me how big
of the shortboard I ride
yeah I swear to God what no just open if
this is printed with some dumb [__] no
no just open
it
okay these are nice right yeah it looks
like a normal
board happy birthday
thanks
what
[Laughter]
what happy birthday thanks
man what I worked out for you
I worked out for that photo this is what
I've been training for this is why I
botle that gym equipment this a nice
board
dude I want to ride this board I I know
I don't want to ride
this no that's I don't want to ride
anything to do with this come on man
no I'm not going to come
on
no damn well thank you
bro this is going right beside the
[Laughter]
like this is like that's in there
there's no there's no taking this off
there's no this is like in the
fiberglass you don't think we could
change it no I don't think so You' have
to like reeal it or like no I don't
think you can maybe we email them and
say you got the nipples wrong can we do
it better yeah maybe we can get them to
send a
[Laughter]
Cody Surf
Shack come on down to Cody Surf Shack we
got all kinds of boards we got a whole
selection of used boards or brand new
boards new boards never been used I
think your face is turning the wrong way
no no no it's the right way no no no no
it's a model pose right it's like this
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah oh I see now
yeah it looks pretty
similar yeah you really got yeah you
really got a snear yeah there you go get
that smile yeah there you
go thank you
dude oh man all for the meme yeah thank
you so much yeah that bicep looks like a
nut sack right yeah it really does oh oh
what these are Uggs first of all got you
a cake thank you oh my God look at this
you guys we got you a cake want you
shouldn't have I wanted to get you a
cake it's got a it says something on the
bottom happy birthday to my
Everlasting what does that say
partner Everlasting partner that was you
that wrote that Everlasting
partner that's what it says
right what do you want it to say oh I
said my podcasting
[Laughter]
partner why' they make it like a like a
wedding
cake oh yeah I guess it is kind of
wedding is it a wedding cake I think
they maybe misinterpreted what I had
requested actually I think so or is this
a bit
I just called in and said I need a cake
for my podcasting
partner Everlasting
partner this is pretty
funny so you got me a wedding cake I
guess so congratulations thanks man
should we should we eat some should we
do this yeah no dude the how you went
just for the mouth just it looks like a
you got shot through your head
dude damn that looks like a gunshot
wound that's [__] good
that's oh that top is
overpowering that was bad the best way
to eat cake is through a
hole everyone knows
that it's cake is not very good it's
pretty good tastes how like a pet store
smells kind of does yeah what the [__]
yeah this tastes like petmart are you
joking how do they do that yeah I feel
bad for whoever gets these cakes for
their for their wedding yeah yeah
where's this cake
from what's the store let's put it on
blast oh yeah yeah yeah let's not do
that let's not do that what's the place
this [__] shitty cake is
from this is yeah this is how my family
ate cakes growing up just threw one hole
at the top and we all just we all just
forked the hole Yeah
would anyone like some cake I would like
some
[Laughter]
cake what's the plan for the big
birthday I'm still not over these shoes
Uggs I know they're Uggs I wasn't sure
and then I tried them on and I was like
oh I get it now why cuz they're just
soft and then I looked in the mirror and
I was like I actually kind of like the
way they look plus it's fall yeah no so
they're comfortable put your foot slide
your foot in there dude knowing slide
your freaking knowing what organisms
live your foot I'm not even taking a
risk yeah my foot is
botulism that's what's in that can is
the [__] living in your foot
dude try that sucker on dude just
trust camera camera eyes up not even in
the socks eyes up eyes
up
yeah it looks good
too oh yeah you get it now
no